很久沒見,很高興吧,很高興
今天能夠在香港你能接受我的這個邀請來做個訪談
這是一次非常重要的訪談
因為一直以來咱們經歷了很多很多的故事
你和比亞迪之間,甚至包括和我個人
那麼這是個難得的復盤
對於比亞迪而言,你不僅僅是一個重要的投資者
你更是我們的老朋友
而且也是我們比亞迪的發展、資本市場
以及公司發展以來重要的參與者和見證者
也是非常多重要節點的建議者
所以說我們想跟您花點時間
我們來聊一聊在過去整理整理思路
回顧一下過去,展望一下未來
你還記不記得你第一次什麼時候聽到比亞迪這三個名字
是什麼樣的場景,你知道了比亞迪
你當時知道了比亞迪,你的第一印象是啥
這個算起來差不多有25年了
大概2000年初
我在閱讀一本trade magazine
就是一個技術性的一個刊物
我讀到了一則消息
就是一家中國的公司現在開始在做rechargeable battery
對這個手機
當時的去報道連Motorola是最大的
如日中天的
根據那個雜誌的報道
在使用這家中國的公司
當時我也沒有太注意這個名字
但是中國公司這件事就引起了我的注意
因為在這個之前我剛剛在研究一個案例
一個投資的案例
美國的一個很著名的battery公司
想去使用鋰電池來去做rechargeable
因為那個時候的battery都是一次性的
那個時候能夠使用rechargeable的只有幾家日本公司
所以這件事就對我非常的有印象
就記住了這個公司
2000年
對
那麼過了兩年
我就發現這家公司就開始上市了
然後確實有報道
Motorola真的在使用這家公司
那麼我查到正好它在美國有一個
就在Motorola邊上
在芝加哥有一個辦事處
所以我就直接打電話
太厲害了
這個接電話的就是Stella
就是Stella
那個時候我不知道她有這麼重要
所以我們就聊了一下
聊了一下
我是對技術問題很有興趣
對她怎麼解決的這個問題非常的有興趣
她說好
我們的創始人對技術非常的了解
可能我們電話之後很快
她說她會到芝加哥來
她說我可以安排你去見一見
我說太好了
大概這個電話過後不久
王總就來了
那是上完學之後
對了
大概秋天的樣子吧
秋天的樣子
然後我就飛過去了
我們就是安排了她臨座的時間
就在機場邊上一個很小的hotel裡
原來她給我安排大概就
見個半個小時一個小時了解一下情況
但是我跟王總一見如故
一聊聊了好幾個小時
就把時間也都忘掉了
所以這一次是讓我真正的了解了
比亞特殊的地方
所以在那個之後很快
我就決定開始真正的了解這間公司
了解了以後
我們買了第一份股份
現在已經23年了
這些股份都還在
當然我非常清楚
日子過得也很快
那是2002年7月份上的市
然後你應該是秋天左右
跟王總見面
你就不久
我的是97年創建的公司
98年開始賺的
那個時候規模還是蠻小的
應該你是倉位比較重
跟今天比金額不是大
但是倉位還可以
是的
我印象是可能有十個點的倉位
因為我們的基本的風格相對來說比較集中
然後持有時間比較長
但是去選一些比較特殊的公司
我還是記憶很深刻的
您和一般的投資人不太一樣
後來我陪王總和您也見過多次
每一次像我這種財務背景的人
基本就插不進嘴
一個小時甚至兩個小時
你和王總都是在不斷的去討論戰略
產品技術
其實可能財務的數字
只是輕描淡寫的去了解一下
主要是去了解財務結構
而並不是過於拘泥於冰冷的財務數據
這點也是一直讓我很感慨
也學習到很多真正的價值投資
應該是這樣的一個過程
那麼王總當時留給您是什麼樣的一個印象
印象非常的深
我的三十幾年一直研究的是
什麼樣的企業能夠成功
什麼樣的企業會失敗
企業發展的過程
商業的歷史
這中間就離不開
這些特殊的企業家本身的特質
一般的企業都是創始人的延伸
至少在早期的時候是這樣的
帶有很強的創始人的痕跡
我們從第一次開始聊天
一直到現在
過了二十幾年
每年都會有很深入的交流
那麼王總這些年一直沒有變化
在一些根本的方面
第一它確實是原創性的
那麼馬斯克後來用這個詞
叫第一性原理思維
科學性的思維
物理學的思維
用第一性思維來思考戰略問題
用工程師的思維方式來解決問題
落地執行
同時擁有堅定的意志
不畏任何艱難
也敢於成功
同時它對於一個商業的利益攸關者
始終抱有受託人的精神
受託人的責任
無論是對股東還是對員工
還是對經銷商
還是對客戶
這樣的一個combination
其實是很rare的
很難找到
我當時就很驚訝
它在整個公司上市之前沒有過VC
它承諾給所有人的股份
其實一直都是由它來去直接弄
所以它沒有VC
實際上是沒有帶入去的
但是它的股份一直在降低
一直在給大家
這樣就使得我們很容易去信任它
一起去面對各種各樣的困難挑戰
所以我這二十幾年裡面
我們經歷過無數的困難
無數的挑戰
無數的艱難的時刻
但是我從來沒有懷疑過
我們的利益和創始人的利益是完全一致的
它的所有公司的各種各樣的商業
全都在同一家公司裡
外面沒有
在分紅之前
它除了基本的工資之外
也沒有別的收入
它全副的經歷
所有公司的IP
它全部的創意都在同一個地方
我們和王主席的利益
永遠在一起
所以這樣的一個結合
真的是一個非常了不起的結合
用第一性的思維來思考戰略問題
用工程師的思維來解決實際的問題
堅韌不拔
永不言敗
直到成功
用順托人的精神和責任
讓所有人信任
願意跟你一起去走過千山萬水
直到成功
所以這種企業家
是在任何一個時代都是鳳毛民膠
一旦發現了之後
要值得終身的珍惜
一定要抓住它
一定要就是它吧
是的 我也很感慨
就是說王總在比亞迪眼中
或者在我李奇的眼中
一定是神一樣存在的
也是我這一輩子
能夠給我個人創造人生價值的
這麼一個貴人、領路人
但是我也很感慨
其實那個時候王總才36歲
你也是36歲
我們兩個同年
差兩個月
都是36歲
剛才你提到了其實商業的本質
說明了王總有看的
他已經看透了
比如關於分享
關於分享
他一直以來對於團隊的基地和利益分配
他是非常非常的大度和公平
而且是有長期考量
因為我在他身邊這個崗位
我一定是知道王總的長期考量在哪
對於上下游的各種利益關係
他非常清楚他的責任和擔當
其次他又有韌勁
又有這種工程師的這種專業的能力
和打不垮的精神
所以這是比亞迪的內核
這也是比亞迪
第一次見到他
就強烈地感受到前面的幾種特質
後面他的意志、決心、抗壓的能力
還有他的受託人精神
是在後面慢慢地感受的越來越深
而且越來越強化
但是他的第一性原理的思維方式
他用工程師的方式解決問題的能力
我們在第一次見面的時候
幾個小時長談
我就感觸非常的深刻
這一點從始至終都是這樣
都是這樣
王總的性格就是永不滿足
這個時候您可能2002年7月份上市的時候
我們只是坐著插著個白錘
沒錯
而且是個小公司
但是是個很有特點的公司
而且王總是個有特點的企業家
但是2003年一開年
王總就給資本市場炸了一個大壘
王總要進軍汽車產業
收購群船汽車
股價暴跌
我們比亞迪和資本市場的關係
當天就進入到了冰點
您當時已經是投資人了
您的第一反應是什麼
我沒什麼特別的反應
因為用第一性原理思考的人
他的商業是沒有邊界的
他的邊界就是不違反科學的原理
不違反物理學的基本原則都可以做
而落地的時候是要用工程式思維
所以我的最關心的問題是怎麼做到這點
這個生意是不是很好的生意
他的基本的想法
這個我們就不斷地去交流
不斷地去學
這個行業本身是一個巨大的行業
這是毫無疑問的
中國公司有很多的優勢
這個是一個特別困難的這個商業
而且是一個著名的粉廠
著名的粉廠
對
掩埋了無數的線路
當時其實中國很多公司都要進軍汽車
最後都埋下去了
包括這個群船
包括收購的群船
群船這個例子
這是我的基本的反應
我是想了解更多的怎麼把它做好
有什麼不同的方式去做
那麼王總其實做這個收購群船的公司
要做汽車
但是從一開始實際上他是已經考慮到了
電池本身的發展
將來是有可能支撐更大的動力
李電池的發展本身已經開始出現了這個曲線
這個曲線是可以最後導致
它能夠便宜和有足夠的動力
去支撐一個很大的載體
就是汽車
這就是第一性思維的使然
但是這個過程要落地
是一個很漫長
需要工程師的思維去一點點把它做起來
那麼他的想法呢
是先把傳統車做匯、做通
然後呢在時機成熟的時候
把電池成熟的時候再疊加上去
來觸動這個變化
在這個時候呢
其實我同時呢
在和Tesla接觸
那個時候的Tesla呢
還不是Elon Musk還沒有完全入主
他是一個投資人
那個時候的創始人叫Martin
所以他們也在考慮
是不是我也去
我有幾個朋友是他
蠻大的投資人
他們也想讓我去加入
所以我也在瞭解這個整個這個過程
可以說就是說
比外地和Tesla幾乎是同時
在兩個不同的國家
都在探索電動車的
顛覆傳統車的可能性
當然歷史最後的情況呢
就是這兩家公司
真正的引導了這次革命性的變化
那麼到了05年呢
比亞迪的第一款車F3燃油車出來
應該講是一炮打紅吧
用燃油車來支持著比亞迪的整個
電動車的持續的研發投入
但是說實在的
那個時候比亞迪還是多條腿走路
電池仍然在做
汽車在投入
零部件是代工產業
也開始起來
從資產負債表的角度
當時還是非常的負擔非常重
研發呢又是王總
一直非常堅持的方向
在那個時間點到了07年
當時資產負債表如果
我們還記得應該講
已經到了一個崩在懸崖邊上的
當時的諾基亞我記得非常清楚
想給你代工業務
但是又怕你撐不住
在那個背景下我們開始了
比亞迪電子的分拆上市
對比亞電子分拆上市
當時也是您在支持著王總
要把他分拆要求母子
比亞迪電子的分拆是個痛苦的過程
但是我們還好
就說我們也堅定
這個世界一定會饋贈
那些正值錢努力的人
所以我們在07年底
我們改成個末班車
最後一秒咱們上的車
2007年12月份
籌集了足夠的資金
對募了67億港幣
這樣子讓2008年的
金融危機來臨的時候
比亞迪依然平穩度過
還會可以持續大力研發
所以08年坦白說對比亞迪而言
我們沒有感覺到什麼叫做
金融危機的寒冬
而且08年我們還發生了
一個高官時刻的事
08年您介紹巴菲特入口比亞迪了
我想請問您
為什麼要把巴菲特介紹給比亞迪
您當時是怎麼想的
以及為什麼是08年
不是07年也不是09年
我們的整個發展的過程
就是邊界不斷在拓寬
不斷在重新定義製造邊界的過程
做了很多
但是這一些其實都是
要讓我們能夠在一個過渡時間
持續的把電池的研發
繼續做下去
然後對汽車的基本的製造能力
繼續掌握
還是在去思考著有一天
這個行業會發生革命式的
飯式的變化
那個時候我們要處在最合適的狀態下去
做這件事
所以這些其實都是互相去作用的
到了08年09年金融危機的時候
我們其實處的位置還可以還不錯
但是整個世界經濟
從美國的視角看
確實是面臨著崩潰的可能性
包括其實我們的股價
所有公司的股價
整個中國市場的股價
我們確實處在相對蠻好的位置
我一直還是希望
在整個中國發展的過程中
尤其像比亞迪這樣
特殊的發展過程中
我們要真正的去走出一條
前人沒有走過的
真正的一條了不起的大路
我們還是要有一些特殊的能量輸入
如果我們的研發
如果我們的製造能力
逐漸地在往前推進
總有一天
我們是有可能去顛覆這個行業
我們要真正做到這點
需要很多很多的加持
一個很重要的加持
不僅是資本的加持
還是我們生意的加持
因為這一些年
我已經比較有信心了
對於王總還有公司
還有我們未來的發展
各個方面都建立起
越來越強的信心
這個跟股價沒有什麼關係
對公司本身的價值創造
是完全相關的
所以我建立起來這樣的信心
我也知道我們要再往下走
我們需要一些外面的協助
我們需要在生育上做得更好
而且我們當時受到打擊最大
其實還是在生育上
如果在那一刻崩潰
我們的所有的努力
還有公司的潛能
就會被扼殺在搖籃裡
但是公司本身這個時候的發展
已經完全具備了成為革命者的
全部的陪胎
顛覆者的全部的陪胎
所以它的外界的壓力
還有我們整個市場的perception
讓股價和我們實際的能力
形成了一個巨大的落差
所以這個時候也為投資者
帶來了一次非常好的機會
所以這個時候引入我信任
尊重的投資者
就在價值上成為革命者
那麼因為這些年
我和芒格先生從2003年2004年
結成了投資合夥人的關係
從此芒格先生成了我終身的
良師義友
又是商業上的合夥人
通過我的基金
其實芒格家族已經在那個時候
擁有比亞迪至少4年了
在這個過程中
我也一直在介紹比亞迪這間公司
它的夢想 它的能力
它不斷拓展的邊際
它將來面臨的機遇
那麼當時面臨的狀況
它的內在價值還有股價
還有其他的亞迪
就這些都形成一個共性
就在08年的時候
公司也需要這樣的生意的加持
這個時候加持又是一個投資
比亞迪一個非常好的時機
價格和價值形成了
一個巨大的落差
所以這個是一個共贏的事情
所以就在08年 07年的時候
我開始去推動這件事情
那麼當然我們也非常幸運
這件事情後來成為可能
讓我們公司在比較短的時間
獲得了全世界的關注
當它真正的具備了成為顛覆者的時候
它已經具備了這樣的聲譽
這個聲譽又合上我們自身的能力
這個自身的能力在不斷的到了節點的時候
就出現了一次巨大的爆發
這使得公司上了一個了不起的台階
這個就是一個共贏的事情
對於Porsche是一個共贏的事情
對比亞迪是一個共贏的事情
對中國的資本市場也是一個共贏的事情
就讓世界第一次了解到
在中國正在發生的神奇性的
革命性的技術性的變化
這是一個特別奇妙的旅行對我來講
因為一開始說巴菲特投比亞迪的時候
當你把這個消息傳到我們這來說
其實從我個人內心裡面覺得
這怎麼可能
後來我在巴菲特的股東大會裡面的發言裡面
也對王總以及對我們幾位團隊
比亞迪也是高度保密的
只有三四個人知道
包括我在內也是高度評價
在這一個多月內我們並沒有去炒作
我們的股價非常的平穩
沒有變化
這也是一定程度上也體現了這個團隊
是一個有職業操作的團隊
咱們敲定那天開完電話會議
晚上當天我熬了個通宵
我準備協議準備發布會
然後第二天早晨我很早就答應了
國內的一個券賬
他們來三四個投資人來比亞迪調研
我其實熬了整個通宵
但是我答應了他我要接待
我第二天還是要去接待一下
王總還打電話給我
身體沒問題吧
我說王總沒問題
協議基本定了
咱們就看當天股價不移動就好了
這個deal就完成
然後我認真地接待
我接待完了這半個小時
他們也是參觀工廠
我就對他們說對不起
我的同事陪你去工廠
我還有一件重要的事情要處理
結果到了當天晚上新聞出來
是巴菲特入宮比亞迪
其中的一位投資人還是誰
把他給了記者
記者寫到新聞上說
他們在接待比亞迪董毅李前說
我還有一個重要的事情接待
原來這件事情是巴菲特入宮比亞迪
我們8塊04收的盤
8塊錢的定價
當天禮拜一開盤16
後來衝到了80
所以這對我而言
是我人生的一個高光時刻之一
也是要感謝李路總
您創造了這個契機
沒有我們共同的這個不是我
是因為比亞迪值得投資
這也是雙贏
雙向奔赴
那麼蒙古其實也一直評價您
他最好的投資就是您
然後在整個資本市場圈
毫無疑問您是華人的投資巨匠
這也是大家公認的
包括也是我心理上的
這個是過獎的
但是也是我心理上的
對您的一個崇拜或者高度認可
但實際上這件事情
我覺得更有意義的是什麼
你架起了中國和西方的橋樑
正是因為這一次投資
中國跟西方資本市場
尤其像巴菲特這種Berkshire
如此偉大的投資公司
與中國企業之間的紐帶的鏈接
甚至於我認為這個影響
遠超過了這個掙錢本身
到今天比亞迪國際化
我們能夠在海外
以兩三年的時間
走完別人十年
甚至幾十年的國際化的路
我個人認為也是與當時的入股
讓比亞迪在全球聲名雀起
也是有息息相關的
今天我們走到全球
資本市場都知道
哇 BYD
多種原因
我相信這也是重要的原因之一
巴菲特入股之後呢
比亞迪聲名雀起
股票從8塊錢一把漲到80
一年的時間漲到80
成為了全世界或者說全香港
資本市場最受關注的那個量載
那麼我們在09年10年的整個發展
也是大跨步的往前走
但是坦白的說
那個時候我們的步子有點大
到了1年呢
王總在公司內部大會上
也開始反思
那個時候我們遇到了種種的挑戰
其實損益表開始出問題
其實盈利上有問題
從而也帶來了投入有大
資產負債表也遇到挑戰
尤其重要的是上下游的夥伴
客戶受到了傷害
我們的其實F6
等一系列的車型並不成功
我們的經銷商我們的退往試電
王總也在反思我們過去三年
認為是個調整區
那我想您作為我們最堅實的投資者
在當時這幾年的過程
你心裡產生變化了嗎
就這樣啊
我們這個關注的這個公司呢
是它的長期內在價值的變化
其實股價的變化對我們影響
確實不是太大
無論是它漲了十倍
還是後來跌了80%
其實我們既沒有一股賣掉
也沒有一股買進來
我們還是原來的基本的實倉
但是這三年呢
公司本身發生了很大的變化
一方面它在很多方面都高歌猛進
另一方面呢
又在高歌猛進中犯下了一系列
可能這個行業都會犯的錯誤
就你回頭來看呢
比阿迪在這幾年犯的錯誤
其實在過去這個行業
為什麼是著名的墳場
是有道理的
其他的企業
在它的發展不同的過程中
很多犯過類似的錯誤
也有很多失敗
也有很多徹底消失
所以這個行業
首先是充滿了挑戰的行業
但是我們很重要的一點呢
就是在整個這個拓展的過程中
其實我們一直想做的事
仍然是拓展我們對於車本身的理解
對它整個零部件的理解
對它規模化生產的把控
考慮的還是這個電池
如果發展到足夠的階段
這場革命還是會發生
但是在這個過程中
我們有好多行業
是要養未來的行業
互相的去養
但是在這個養的過程中
這個行業養別的行業呢
就特別的困難
辛苦
而且充滿了挑戰和風險
那麼在這三年裡面
我們對這一點體會的尤其深刻
所以這個事呢
給了我們很大很大的教訓
但是確實也是成長中的煩惱
也是我們必須要經歷的這個過程
我並沒有覺得這個
有什麼特殊的地方
因為這樣的錯誤
幾乎所有的車企都經歷過
那麼經歷不過去
這個坎過不去的就進入到墳場
過去的跨過去的
就會成為後來的偉大的公司
所以對我們的考驗
其實還是能不能跨過這道坎
在這點上我們又回到原來的
一直的信任
就是我相信我們的團隊
我們相信我們很多的先天的優勢
也相信我們學習的能力
我們其實這些年還有一點呢
大家還是保持了這個平常心
就是也不會把自己太當回事
無論別人怎麼去評價你
至少我不認為我是什麼神奇
我也不認為王總自己是多少神奇
我們該犯的錯誤都要犯
該要的學習都要學習
但是要堅持永遠的錯誤學習
最好是從別人的錯誤中學習
不要老在自己的錯誤中學習
這個代價比較大
但是犯了錯誤學習
面對現實然後永不言敗
繼續往前走
這是一個企業能夠走下去
根本的要求
我們不是去學習別人
我們是開拓者
後來學習的要容易多了
開拓者是很難很難
你要製造一個不存在的市場
所以你一定要具備很多很多不同的能力
但是具備多少這個度很難把握
所以在這些問題上的探索
有的時候這個錯誤是必要的
這些代價是必須要付出的
每一個成功的企業都要經歷
一系列的鳳凰面板
它不可能就一蹴而就了
所以我還是對你充滿了感謝
您對我的人生也是充滿著啟發
我記得11年左右吧
我有點繃不住了
我對種種的失誤我沒有逃避
我沒有放棄
我也在想公司要改變
要找解決辦法
我不知道你還記得我到洛杉磯
當時你還在洛杉磯
對我在洛杉磯
我到您洛杉磯
我到您辦公室
咱倆也是深聊了兩三個小時
可能那個時候我也年輕
我的表達相對更直接
我在找救命稻草
去希望能夠讓公司變得更好
那次聊天對我的人生
是充滿著啟發和重要意義的一次聊天
因為我得到了我的滿意的答覆
或者說我得到了希望鼓勵
您不斷地在鼓勵我
您就是用剛才講的第一性原理
您也跟我講
你說李前
我見了非常多的中國企業家
來我這裡交流
我中國的企業家
我這些最好的企業家們
我都熟悉
但是像王總如此有韌勁
對科學探索的無盡的渴望
如此有邊界感的企業家不多
就衝著這一點
你相信比亞迪
一定會越來越好
這是當時我們那兩三個小時
你給我的最大的鼓勵
我記憶非常的猶新
後來在資本市場
因為當時您說到了
一個產業去孵另一個產業
尤其拿汽車這個產業去孵其他產業
而且王總是
性格上又是非常的堅決
研發投入是不可以放棄的
沒錯
不管我經營怎麼樣
今天還是這樣
所以那幾年
我的壓力也是比較大的
從12年上市A股上市
13年做點心債
14年閃電配售
15年榮151的A股
而這一系列
我和您交流的都是比較多的
也再次感謝你給我的鼓勵
我要感謝你
感謝你在這個過程中
為培植資本市場
培植耐心長期的投資者
對一個成長型的企業
真的是至關重要的
所以你在這麼多年裡面
堅持做這件事情
做得很好
而且建立起別人對你的信念
你做得非常的好
感謝
我也向你感謝
14年發生了一件有意思的事
有一天中午一點多鐘
股價突然就莫名其妙的
百分之十幾
百分之二十幾
百分之三十幾
我的桌上的電話
我的手機
我就已經開始運功不過來了
當時也很有意思
非常多的投資者
堅定的長期投資者
打電話問我
那天跌到50%
一天跌50%
堅定的投資者
常見的他就問我一句話
李前公司有問題沒有
我給他們說公司沒問題
他們就堅定的敢買了
但是其實我心裡面也沒底
因為資本市場股價的表現
不只是公司有沒有問題
其實還有很多外在的環境
比如我第一時間我問王總
王總公司有沒有什麼
事情我不知道的
王總跟我說李前沒有
我基本上就敢回答投資者
公司沒有問題
緊跟著謠言四起
八飛都要減持了
李祿要減持了
我當時坦白說我不知道你在哪
但是我不管
我不管是晚上幾點了
我就給你打了個電話
您也很巧
您當時應該在國內
在飛機上
你跟我說李前我在飛機上
太好了您接回電話了
我說李祿總現在股價
你看看股價
股價怎麼了
我說股價已經跌了
股價已經跌了百分之四五十了
我說江湖在傳李祿總
您在減持
當時您給了我一個堅定的回答
你說李前
對
一定不是我
第二我對公司充滿信心
對
然後有了這個回答
我就敢於向資本市場去傳遞
第一公司沒問題
第二李祿總沒有減持
喜巴拉也沒有減持
我們是當天晚上
巴奎特這邊早晨
我們聯繫上了
知道了他沒有動作
所以在第二天早晨的七點鐘
王總和我
召開了一個記者發佈會
我們給市場澄清了
當天的股價就漲回百分之三十
後來又回到了原來的位置
而且我也再次表示感謝
您又買了三百多萬
因為您看到的是比亞迪的價值
您又繼續支持了比亞迪
王總當時也非常的感慨
其實那個時候公司的經營情況
並不是說在已經出現拐點
當時您也是為了堅定您的信念
也是堅定對比亞迪的信念
2020年我們後繼爆發
當年發生兩件事
第一個疫情
比亞迪發揮了我們的
中國製造最典型的搞笑
軍團作戰
我們的口罩
然後六月份推出來的漢
一炮大火
在這個過程中
在您跟王總有些什麼樣的交流
因為你也是王總的志友
也是支持者和建議者
在那個關鍵的節點
你和王總的交流的狀態是什麼
19年底2020年初
這個也是一個特發的事情
我們最早口罩的起因
因為我們剛剛發生
武漢的疫情之後
那個時候也是因為
我們看到這種需求非常的交集
所以我在美國
發起了一個天使基金會
就是要在美國去動員
能夠動員各種各樣的人力
物理財力去支援武漢
那麼當時我遇到的最大的挑戰
就是我們買口罩買不著
買口罩變得很困難的一件事情
我到處去找
然後運力一開始
發生各種各樣的困難
一個一個的解決
但是解決了以後
其實我們錢也籌到
我自己也投入了很多錢
但是我們買不到
就買的很少
我們能買到的全部買來了
所以當時我跟王總
正好在假期的時候在一起
這個時候我跟他談了
我們在做的這個事
他就問我這個最困難的
什麼地方是毒點結點
我跟他說口罩
這是我的最大的毒點
他說我來想一想辦法
他這個當天晚上
立刻讓這個回去
動員所有的事業部
我們開會
馬上我們開會了
分工
這個事可以解決
當時說實話我也很驚訝
但是確確實實在之後
慢慢的他就真的做起來了
這個時候又是芒格先生的幫助
那麼我們就跟Costco建立起背書
也是用信譽來去背書
有這樣的製造能力
這是一家了不起的公司
然後關鍵的是我們的美國的認證
還是做得比較完整
在中國已經開始使用
而且非常的有這張口罩
所以我們第一筆大的訂單
就是在Costco6000萬口罩
所以這一下子
就讓我們很多其他地方
因為有這個Costco
我們最早有芒格先生背書
有Costco的第一個訂單
然後之後其他的
有各個地方的需求
全球都來了
一下子一起來
都來了
我們最後賣了在全球賣了幾十億口罩
所以這個過程
又是一個非常有趣的過程
又再次見證了
第一比亞迪的製造能力
真的是我們邊界的製造能力
原創型的思維
第一性原理的思維
工程師的落地
還有受託人的精神
完全不被困難
堅定的毅力
在這刻就爆發出來
在幾個月的時間
我們從一紙手上都沒有
變成了全世界最大的口罩製造商
一天一名一紙
也是個神奇的過程
那麼這個時候
比亞迪和Berkshire合作
中國和美國互相的信任和背書
又在這一次發揮了巨大的力量
能夠在這一點很短的時間裡
基本上從消費者到各個州
到美國聯邦政府
到歐洲的國家
所有的全球都在很短的時間
接受了比亞迪的產品
它的質量它的細膩
也確確實實幫助了無數的人
也是驗證了你剛才說的
你不斷地去幫助別人
幫助別人確實有好報
達人助己
真的是這個樣子
活靈活現
在短短六個月裡面
體現的淋漓盡致
真的是這樣
在比亞迪做口罩之前
全中國的整個口罩產能
一天是兩千萬紙
我們比亞迪三天出圖紙
七天收藏生產線
從五百萬紙一天開始
我們很快到了一個多月
就到了一億紙
是全中國所有口罩產能的五倍
而且為中國和全球的紐帶關係
也做出了巨大的貢獻
也為中國的這次防禦
做出了巨大的貢獻
也彰顯了中國製造的能力和優勢
也建立了品牌在海外
幫了人
對 那個時候全球的
中國之外的生產能力
也是只有兩千萬
加在一起全球的生產力就是四千萬
比亞迪一家
最後在六個月裡
今天的比亞迪
已經是一個中國的世界冠軍
但是比亞迪是一個充滿夢想的公司
我們正在從中國的世界冠軍
要蛻變成全球的領袖
您覺得比亞迪還有什麼樣的路要走
還會遇到這些困難和挑戰
技術上 公司治理上
企業文化上 全球責任上
等等我相信
也不會那麼一蹴而就
所以我特別想聽聽您這位智者
從您對人類的文明史
對科技發展的進步和迭代
對價值的發現
給比亞迪再提提一些什麼想法和建議
智者談不上
我們一個真正偉大的企業
實際上是沒有邊界的
它的發展也不會停止下來
增長也沒有天花板
我們其實
雖然走了一條很長的路
但是還有更長的路要走
中國在這個節點上發展
也開始進入到一個新的台階
各方面的元素
都使得我們下面的幾十年的發展
其實更值得期待
首先就是全球公司這個概念
Multinational Corporation
最早工業化的歐洲的國家
後來二戰之後的美部國家
實現了真正雖然基於一個國家
但是商業在全球同時發展
那麼現在這個節點上
中國公司開始具備了這樣的機會
這樣的能量這樣的能力
中國提供給這些公司最重要的條件
就是它是一個巨大的
單一的
大的市場
它又單一
又統一
從regulation上
然後又巨大
同時是市場
是一個開放型的
對全球開放型的市場
這些四個條件合在一起
就使得在這個市場裡面的冠軍
有機會在全球都成為冠軍
而且它一定在當地化
成為當地經濟發展的一步
不僅僅是出口
所以這個時代是會出現
以中國為基礎的全球公司
中國籍的全球公司
比亞迪是這個浪潮裡面的
重要的一朵浪花
不是唯一的
當然
這個過程才剛剛開始
還有很長很長的路
要走可走
這是一個方面
另一個方面
中國經過四五十年的發展
我們也開始具備了
人才技術市場
各個方面
都到了一個
創造力爆發的這樣一個時代
就在這個時代裡頭
原創的技術
原創的產品
了不起的定義行業的企業
都會密集性地出現
在幾乎所有的領域
所以在這個時代
對於一個沒有邊界的企業
能夠用低性原理來思考
公司未來的前進的企業
能夠有工程師的文化
我們又有勞動力的鼓勵
又有工程師的鼓勵
又有技術的積累
所以它能夠去
爆發出的創造力會更燦爛
所以在這個時候
比亞迪是非常幸運的
在這個時代
它就具備了生育
具備了技術的儲備
人才的儲備
規模的優勢
產品的領先
品牌的名譽度
所有這些都在一起
再加上我們的創學
還有公司的員工
仍然處在旺盛的
年齡段和經歷
還在旺盛的時期
我認識王祖二十幾年
他這個生活
沒有發生過什麼變化
依舊
仍然是從早一直到半夜
然後第二天重新開始
我們一起要在外面去旅行
尤其說團隊去
一天最重要的會
永遠是晚上11點
就是白天所有的工作做完了
11點又開始總結了
然後睡覺之後
第二天早上又開始
精力滿滿
動力滿滿
我們的邊界還很遙遠
增長還非常的值得期待
而在這個時候
又是質量和技術爆發的時代
但是我們雖然在技術上
常常領先
但是在精細化管理方面
其實又是一個處在一個
非常初級的階段
要管理十幾萬的工程師
幾十萬甚至於上百萬的員工
一個很長的一個產品線
在多個國家
我們還要有好多好多的探索
才能夠真正做到精細化的管理
才能真正做到以客戶為中心
把產品真正的做精做細
還有上十萬個專利
而且不斷地在研發出新的方向
所以這些潛力要實現
它一直是不斷地在
擴大期權的過程中
所以它的內在價值一直在增長
所以這個是我們最注看重的
我們作為投資人
你看我們擁有23年的時間
其中股價跌了50%以上
大概至少有七八次
然後一次跌了80%以上
每次漲的也快
但是漲的時候也可以很快
一年十倍的情況也出現過
所以在這個過程中
如果你是一個投機的心態
是很難真正享受到整個的過程的
所以本分一點思考問題
無論是作為管理者還是作為投資人
就掙自己應該掙的這個錢
你應該掙的錢實際上就是
公司本身內在價值不斷地被實現
不斷地增長
最後慢慢被認可時候的你的利益份
當然我們覺得也非常幸運
這樣的企業其實很少很少
如果大家企業都是永遠是增長
這個世界我們就真的是
這書長得天上這個也不太可能
所以這樣的企業是鳳毛連角
我們的幸運是在很早的時候
發現了這樣一個了不起的企業
這樣一個了不起的企業家
而且跟隨著企業一起成長
一起學習
在這個中間有所幫助
讓我們更加心安理得
您謙虛了
這是您的眼光和智慧挖掘
就是說投資它是你認知的結果
就是您相信你才會投比亞迪
也感謝您對比亞迪包容
就像您寫的這本書
就是您寫的這個叫做
文明現代化價值投資與中國
中國也是我非常喜歡的一本書
因為這本書裡面
你對人類文明的整個進化
以及現代科學的一個迭代
包括價值投資的哲學
你是做了一個系統性的描述
也是給我的人生
對我的人生包括投資
都有很多很多的啟發
雖然現在的世界好像有點亂
現在也就網絡名詞叫
世界就是個草苔斑子
但是您又是樂觀的
您對世界的統一大市場
你是長期認為
這是人類發展的必然結果
你也認為文明3.0
應該講要持續為社會和世界
創造出它所需要的價值
這才是根本
我想您剛才對於我提的問題
您的回答應該用這個
也能完美地闡述
只要比亞迪繼續努力
持續為世界和人類
創造更好的更高的價值
那就是我們的使命
我們就能夠去為世界文明做貢獻
而不要去管這個世界
是怎麼個草苔斑子
我們做好我們自己吧
剛才我說了那麼多
王總不變得有
非常多的特點
今天的比亞迪
又站在歷史的一個新的舞臺
假如說從過去的二十幾年
你和王總的交流、友誼
不變得又非常多
但是我又想請問一下
那王總變得又是哪一些呢
一定變得很多
對,我覺得這個王總身上
我覺得最讓我很欽佩的特質
就是他這個學習的能力
持續學習的能力
所以學習本身
也是一個學習了學習的方法之後
他的學習就開始以福利的形式
不斷地在前進
真心地體會到
在過去的二十幾年的
這個王總對於商業的理解
對不同技術的理解
對於實現長期目標短期的量化
對於管理這個龐大
越來越增加的員工和資產
還有市場面臨著各種各樣
複雜的問題
都有著驚人的變化
因為這個就是福利的力量
但是不僅僅是王總
我們這個公司的高管的團隊
大家還在公司裡
我們還在堅持
還有我們下一代更年輕的
這個組織本身
慢慢地就換化成一個學習的組織
應該說還沒有完全的
完全地完成這個過程
我們還要學習的還有很多很多
因為我們增長的這個速度
尤其是在快速增長的時候
它一定會產生很多很多新的問題
我們過去這五年的經驗
其實也不可能這個永遠都複製
這個是不是這個盤整啊
這些都是必然的
所以如果說我們對未來
有一個比較現實的期待的話
我們要該犯的錯誤
新的錯誤我們需要的盤整
這都是必然的
也沒什麼大不了
這個過去的這些經驗
讓我們更加有信心
遇到不同的問題
挑戰的時候呢
就真正地一步一步地去應對它
每個你走很長很長的路
其實都是左腳在前
右腳在前
左腳在前
一步一步都是這樣走的
關鍵是不停地走
不停地走就能夠走得很遠
同時堅定地相信走的方向
我的想法呢
就是基於理性和常識的樂觀
仍然是人類最好的選擇
但是要基於理性
基於常識
在這個基礎上
堅定的樂觀中
是讓我們能夠不斷走下去的路
我們過去的印記
幫我們更加有信心
我們的不斷地學習
讓我們具備更多的理性
更多的常識
更明確的方向
但是堅定的腳印
仍然是通向成功
唯一的辦法
所以我希望還能夠看到
跟比亞迪一起
再走一長遠的道路
作為一路相伴的志友夥伴
我想您給比亞迪下一個30年
最真摯的祝福或者期待
我已經講過了
我沒有什麼特別的
我也不是一個特殊人
我也沒有什麼提出的本質
每天一步一個腳印就可以
不需要去想的那麼遠
每天踏踏實實地向前走
盲哥先生一個話我很喜歡
每天早上醒來的時候
比昨天的都更聰明一點
學習更多一點就可以了
每天如此
福利的力量是強大無比的
外面的盤整可以很多
但是內在的進步
是我們自己都能夠感受到的
我們只要每天都能夠比前一天
稍稍的學習多一點
我們就可以走很遠很遠的道路
所以這種態度
是一個企業能夠去長久走下去
根本文化不僅是個人
把整個企業打造成這樣一個學習的機器
能夠不斷以福利的方式去前進
我們就能走很久
這是送給比亞迪的
也是送給我的
我感謝能夠今天這一個多小時的交流
也感謝一直以來你給我的
精神上的一些鼓勵和支持
我希望以後多有機會能向您請教
也希望您一直陪伴著比亞迪
我們一起變得每天比每天變得好一點
聰明一點
是的
非常感謝
我作為股東真的是對於所有的比亞迪員工
無論是今天的還是過去的還是未來的
心存感激之心
非常非常的感謝
再次謝謝李總總
謝謝